LILIANA YU: Hey
there, Liliana here.
I'm an operations program
manager here at Google,
and I work on our maps
and search products.
SAMAN JAVAN: And
hi from me, Saman.
I'm a curriculum developer
here at Google too,
developing GCP, Enterprise,
and sales training.
On this episode,
we'll be looking
at Cloud Dataproc, a faster,
easier, more cost effective way
to run Apache Spark
and Apache Hadoop.
LILIANA YU: We'll also take
you through a quick demo
of a self-paced lab where we use
a GCP console to create a Cloud
Dataproc cluster, run
a simple Spark job,
and change the number
of worker nodes.
SAMAN JAVAN: If you're using
popular data processing tools
like Hadoop and Spark, you're
probably spending more time
than you want on managing
the balance between cost,
complexity, scale,
and utilization.
LILIANA YU: Absolutely.
When I've got vast quantities
of data to process,
I want to be focusing on
the insights provided,
not the cluster processing it.
As a managed Spark and
Hadoop cloud service,
Cloud Dataproc makes
these powerful data tools
easy to use.
SAMAN JAVAN: What you don't
want to be worrying about
in data processing is
cost and complexity.
LILIANA YU: Using Spark
and Hadoop shouldn't break
the bank, so on top of the
other GCP resources you use,
there's only a small incremental
fee payable per virtual CPU
in your cluster.
Dataproc automation also
helps you save money
by turning clusters off
when you don't need them.
With billing in one
second clock time
increments, subject
to one minute minimum,
you also only pay
for what you use.
SAMAN JAVAN: Now
time for Qwik labs.
In that's hands
on lab, we'll use
the GCP console to create
a Dataproc cluster,
run a simple Apache
Spark job, then modify
the number of workers
in the cluster.
LILIANA YU: There's
a separate lab
where the same activities can
be completed using the G Cloud
COI2.
You can check out the links
to start the Qwik Labs here.
Each lab will take about
30 minutes to complete.
So far in the lab, we've
created a Dataproc cluster
in the US central region.
We navigate to the
Dataproc Jobs view.
We submit a sample
Spark job that
calculates the value of pi.
We check the job output.
We can see the value of pi
that was calculated by the job.
In the lab, you'll also
have the opportunity
to change the number of worker
instances in your cluster.
SAMAN JAVAN: We hope you've
enjoyed this episode.
We'd love to hear how
Cloud Dataproc has
improved how you run Spark
and Hadoop, so please,
get in touch.
LILIANA YU: And if
you haven't signed up
for the $300 free trial credit
on GCP, check out this link.
It's a great way to apply
what you've learned.
SAMAN JAVAN: All of our
additional training resources
are linked below.
Thanks again for watching
and see you soon.